if you have an iPad you probably use it
for Netflix and gaming and maybe maybe
email every once in a while right well
apples hoping you'll do much more with
it they want this the new nine point
seven inch iPad pro to be your only work
computer for 599 bucks you get one of
Apple's most powerful tablets ever for
another 150 you also get Apple's nifty
keyboard case for another hundred you
get the very cool Apple pencil okay so
eight hundred and fifty bucks about the
same price as Microsoft's awesome
surface pro 4 this is supposedly your
next computer here's basically the best
case scenario for the iPad pro so you're
sitting in a meeting taking notes while
someone writes on the whiteboard you
pick up your iPad take a picture of the
whiteboard and sketch your notes on top
of it then you draw up the design you
talked about and FaceTime with your
co-workers to talk about it being able
to do all this stuff with one device is
really cool and it's even cooler that
that device only weighs a pound and can
just slap in your bag and go anywhere
with you
you don't even have to take it out at
the airport which rules if Apple's going
for the perfect travel gadget rather
than a laptop replacement it definitely
works I've been using this thing for a
while and having something this small
can be really nice if you're on a plane
or in a crowded coffee shop and need to
get some work done
but even though iOS does technically let
you do more than one thing at a time
like watch a movie while working in two
different apps at once everything gets
kind of crowded on the small screen here
it's all fast enough but it's just I
don't know small and a keyboard which is
better than most iPad keyboards is small
too it has a cool new true tone display
which calibrates the color of the screen
to the color of the room which works
really well it has great speakers it's
really fast it's an awesome iPad if you
want an iPad buy this one just don't
throw out your laptop yet